The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Now today's
lecture.
First I want to talk a little
bit about what computer
scientists do.
This whole course has been
about computer science.
And I hope that at least for
many of you, it might have
persuaded you that there's an
interesting career out there
for you as a computer
scientist.
And then I'll finish up with an
overview of what I think we
covered this term.
So what do computer
scientists do?
Well, they look a lot like
that as you all know.
In fact, it's amazing.
There's almost nothing that
computer scientists don't do.
So here I've just collected a
few of the different pictures
related to what computer
scientists in EECS are doing
these days, things like working
on the software that
keeps airplanes from falling
out of the skies.
Quite a few people working in
the movie industry these days
doing animations in 3D and
that sort of thing.
These days, computer scientists
don't get paid as
much as the actors.
But they get paid a lot
to produce movies.
Robots, of course.
A lot of medical work,
particularly medical imaging.
This is a picture where someone
has written software
to try and identify the tumors
in the human brain, and then
will draw little lines telling
the surgeon where to cut so as
to do the least damage
and the most good.
A lot of work in genetics.
And of course, core things
like making the internet
actually not crash.
Fundamentally, what computer
scientists do is they think
computationally.
And I hope that you've
understood that that's been
the theme of 6.00, is how to
formulate problems and think
computationally.
This will be, I think, the most
important skill used by
certainly scientists and
engineers but, in fact,
everybody by the middle of the
21st century or sooner.
People will just do everything
computationally.
And just as once upon a time
maybe it's still important
everyone learn to read and
write and do a little
arithmetic, people will think
that computation is exactly as
important and that you'll have
to know how to formulate
problems computationally
to survive in society.
The process, and this is what
we've been doing all term, is
not an easy one.
But it's not an impossible
one either.
We begin by identifying and
inventing useful abstractions.
Everything we do is an
abstraction of reality.
And as we've gone through the
second half of the term,
almost every interesting
computation we've designed
starts with inventing classes
that give us useful data
abstraction or functions that
compute useful things.
And that's sort of what
we start with.
We start with some existing set
of abstractions, and we
invent new ones that
will help us think
about the current problem.
We then formulate the solution
to the problem as a
computational experiment and
then design and construct a
sufficiently efficient
implementation.
It doesn't have to be the most
efficient one possible.
It just has to be efficient
enough that we can run it and
get an answer.
Of course, before we trust
the answer, as with any
experimental apparatus--
and it is an experimental
apparatus, a program--
we need to validate the
experiment, convince ourselves
that when we run it, we should
believe the answer.
That's the process
of debugging.
And I'm sure it's a process
that all of you have spent
more time on this term then
you might have liked.
I hope by now you feel you are a
little bit better at it than
you used to be.
Once we think we've got the
experiment put together
properly, we run it.
We then evaluate the results.
And then we repeat as
needed, the classic
iterative style of science.
And a lot of this, of course, is
what you would have learned
in your chemistry lab or your
physics lab or the bio lab in
designing any experiment.
You have to go through
a lot of these steps.
And the difference is these
are all computational
experiments.
So we think of there
are two ways of
computational thinking.
There's abstraction.
You have to choose the
right abstraction.
Typically, we operate in terms
of multiple layers of
abstraction simultaneously.
And this is an important part
of thinking computationally.
We have to be able to not worry
about, say, the details
of how floating point numbers
were implemented, but just
assume it's a good
approximation of the real numbers.
That's one level
of abstraction.
And another level of
abstraction, we think about
bus stop queues.
And maybe we have to implement
those ourselves.
And then we have to think about
the relationships among
the layers.
A key thing that makes
computational abstractions
different from so many others
is we can automate them.
So we often think about
abstractions as we go through
life and think about how to cope
with things that are too
complex to understand.
We have these various
abstractions.
Newton gave us some good
abstractions of the physical
world that let us understand
how things like levers and
such almost how they work.
But here we get the big
advantage that we not only can
invent an abstraction,
we can mechanize it.
We can do this for
two reasons.
One, we have a precise and
exacting notation for
expressing the abstractions
for building our
computational models.
This term, that has been Python
and PyLab and NumPy.
But it could have been Java.
It could have been C++.
It could have been MATLAB.
Doesn't matter very much.
What matters is that we have a
notation that's precise enough
that we can actually describe
a computation.
And we have some machine that
can take a computation written
in that notation, or a set of
computations actually written
in that notation, and execute
them and give us results.
And that's been the big
transformation that has made
computation so important.
We've had the notion of
computation long before we had
machines that could
execute them.
The Greeks, the Egyptians
understood notions of
computation, as we've seen
before when we looked at some
early algorithms.
Algorithms have been
around a long time.
But nobody cared very much
until we had machines and
notations that would let us
actually run the algorithms.
That came along in
the late '40s.
And then the world changed
dramatically.
So some examples of
computational thinking.
How difficult is this problem,
and how best can I solve it?
And that's what theoretical
computer scientists spend
their time thinking about.
They try to give precise
meanings to these kinds of
questions so that we can ask
them in the context of, say,
random access machines or
parallel machines or, more
lately, quantum machines, how
do we formulate those
questions precisely?
And how can we answer them?
And of course, thinking
recursively is very important.
Fundamentally, it's the key in
that what we try and do is we
try and reformulate a seemingly
difficult problem
into one we already
know how to solve.
This is what we talked about
before, reduction to a
previously solved problem.
And we've looked at different
ways of doing this.
There is reduction,
as I mentioned.
There's embedding, where, OK,
our problem is complex.
We can't reduce it to
a different problem.
But we can embed a different
problem in it as at least part
of the solution.
We can do some transformations,
take one
problem and transform it
to a different problem.
Usually, a simpler problem that
we know how to solve.
We've seen a lot of that.
That's, of course, what you've
seen in the bus simulation
you're studying, I hope as--
I hope not as I speak, but as
soon as I finish speaking,
you'll be studying it.
We've taken a complex problem
and simplified it by
transforming it into
a simpler problem
that we can then attack.
And we've used a lot of
simulation as a mechanism for
dealing with problems.
So here's a little recursive
picture.
Here's one of my favorite
illustrations of recursion.
I don't know how they
did that, but I
think it's pretty cool.
All right.
That's a very quick
introduction, at a very
abstract level, what computer
scientists might do.
I'm gonna spend some time now
on what one particular
computer scientist does,
and that's me.
Why did I choose me?
Well, not because I'm the most
interesting, but because I'm
the one I know the best.
So it's kind of easier for me
to talk about my work than
about somebody else's.
And the truth be told, it's
not actually my work.
Like all professors, I claim
credit for the work that my
students do.
So all of the work you're going
to see is actually work
that my students have done.
Mostly graduate students,
but also some
very productive UROPs.
So, I won't give them as much
credit as I should, but you
should know in your heart that
I didn't do any of this
actually myself.
All right.
What do we do?
The goals of our research group
is the rather modest one
of helping people live longer
and better quality lives.
Other than that, we don't intend
to accomplish anything.
And we do this mostly in the
medical area by collaborating
with clinical researchers and
practicing clinicians.
Along the way we have a lot of
fun pushing the frontiers, the
state of the art in computer
science, electrical
engineering, and certainly
medicine.
We use a lot of the technical
kind of ideas you've seen this
semester and that you'll see in
almost any computer science
course you take.
We do a lot of machine learning
and data mining.
I'll explain why shortly.
We do a lot of algorithm design
because a lot of the
problems we're trying to solve
are too complex to solve if
you're not clever about
how you solve them.
We do some signal processing.
I'll explain why we do that.
And a lot of just plain-old
software systems are needed.
Do we use databases?
How we build software that
injects electrical signals
into people's brains?
So we spend a fair amount of
time trying to convince
ourselves it actually works,
doesn't inject the wrong
signals at the wrong time.
But that might be fun too.
And these are just the
logos of some of the
hospitals we work with.
So what are some of the problems
we try and deal with?
Probably our longest standing
project has to do with medical
telepresence.
These hands do not belong
to a basketball player.
These are normal sized hands
like yours or mine.
That is not a normal
sized baby.
This is not a Photoshop photo.
This is a real photo.
This is a very small
premature baby.
And we have spent a lot of
time working with groups
figuring out how to provide
better outcomes for these tiny
little, very delicate people.
A problem is that a lot of
these babies are born--
if these babies are born in the
right hospital, Brigham
and Women's Hospital or
something close to Children's
Hospital or MGH, they have
very good outcomes.
They tend to survive, and they
tend to grow up to be
relatively normal.
If these babies are born in a
community hospital that does
not know how to take care of
these kinds of babies, they
have very bad outcomes.
A lot of them die.
Many of them who survive end up
being permanently disabled.
Very sad.
One of the shocking statistics
is that globally there's a
neonatal death every
10 seconds.
Shocking number, I think.
It's just tragic.
And many of these
are unnecessary.
And they occur because there's
not adequate care at the point
where the baby is born.
And so we've been trying to use
technology to link places
where these babies might be born
to places where people
can advise how to take
care of them.
And it turns out to be a very
interesting set of computer
networking communications
problems.
You can't just use Skype
for reasons I won't
have time to go into.
But it's very exciting.
It uses a lot of computer
science, a lot of medicine,
but mostly computer science,
in this case.
And we're actually currently
running some trials in
conjunction with Children's
Hospital Boston where they're
actually trying to look at
babies born elsewhere.
Another problem we've been
looking at is health-care
associated infections.
Approximately 1 in 20 hospital
visits results in the patient
contracting an infection totally
unrelated to the
reason they entered
the hospital.
And today it's among the top ten
leading causes of death in
the United States.
Somebody enters a hospital for
a reason x, picks up an
infection unrelated
to x, and dies.
Not a very good outcome.
And it's particularly
discouraging because, in
principle, these infections
should be preventable.
You shouldn't acquire a
life-threatening infection
while you're in the hospital.
But people do.
We've been trying to
understand why.
We've been working on this
project with Microsoft, which
has provided us with data from
4.5 million different hospital
visits and about 2000 pieces of
information per visit, lab
tests, drug tests, who the
doctors were, who the nurses
were, what rooms they were in.
And we're trying to study--
these are pictures of some of
the most obnoxious of
these infections--
and we've been trying to figure
out what's causing them
and what can be done
not to cause them.
This has been primarily a
machine learning project.
We've been struggling with it.
We've been dealing with exactly
some of the issues we
talked about in class.
Which features are
most important?
How should you weight the
different features?
How can we reduce the number
of features so that we can
actually finish our
computations?
We've been using different kinds
of clustering, different
kinds of supervised learning,
many different techniques.
And we're beginning to get a
handle here on, in fact, what
are some of the causes of these
infections and what
could they be done.
Some of the things are
very disturbing.
Some of them, a lot of them,
seem to be caused by drugs
that are given in
the hospital.
And maybe we can substitute
one drug for another if we
understand that.
At least in some cases they seem
to be related to things
like what room you happen to be
placed in, suggesting that
maybe they're not cleaning
the rooms adequately.
Things like that.
All right.
Another project, probably our
biggest sets of projects, have
to do with extracting
information from
physiological signals.
We've been focusing on the
heart, the brain, and the
connected anatomy.
For those of you who don't
happen to be biology or course
20 majors, here's where the
heart and the brain are
located and what
they look like.
Some of the examples we're
interested in are predicting
adverse cardiac events.
And for that you can think
about death from a heart
event, heart attack.
And we spent a lot of time
dealing with epilepsy.
So let me give a little bit more
detail about these two
examples because each of
them relate to things
we've covered in 6.00.
So epilepsy, an interesting
disease.
Surprisingly, it affects about
1% of the world's population.
When I first heard this,
I was astounded.
Because gee, 1 out
of 100 people
that I know have epilepsy?
And the truth is, yes.
I just didn't know it.
I've been amazed, since it's
become known that I do
research in this area, the
number of people I've known
for years who come up to me
say, you know, I never
mentioned this before, but I
have epilepsy, or my kid has
epilepsy or my parent has
epilepsy, and I have some
questions now that you're
supposed to be
an expert on this.
And I give them the usual
caveats, you know, I'm not a
doctor, I just play
one on television.
But then I tell them go talk
to one of my students.
They're not doctors either,
but they're really smart.
Probably smarter than
your doctor.
All right.
Why is it underestimated when
we do it ourselves?
Well, because they're
still some stigmas.
A few hundred years ago, they
burned women in Salem,
Massachusetts, who had epilepsy
because they thought
the seizures meant they were
possessed by the devil.
Today, if you tell the Registry
of Motor Vehicles
that you have epilepsy, they
won't let you drive an
automobile.
So people tend not
to announce it.
What's it characterized by
is a recurrent seizure.
A seizure is abnormal electrical
activity that
originates and persists
in the brain.
Number of causes.
It can be acquired.
It can be inherited.
There's manifest different
symptoms.
Most of them do not
look like what's
portrayed on the Simpsons.
Slightly more realistically,
and maybe more horrifying.
Here's a picture of a young
girl, a movie, you're gonna
see a seizure.
It's not pleasant, I'm
gonna warn you.
What I want you to notice
is two things.
(1) She's all happy, and
the seizure seems
to come out of nowhere.
She doesn't expect it.
She doesn't know she's
going to have.
It just hits.
That's very important.
(2) She happened to be in the
clinic at the time wearing
this funny looking cap, with
it has electrodes in it.
Just sits on the scalp.
And here is a record of the
electrical activity at the
surface of her scalp.
And what you'll see is a quick
slight change on it just
before the seizure hits, and
then enormous changes during
the seizure.
Turns out that the enormous
changes during the seizure
have nothing really to
do with the seizure.
They have to do with
muscle activity.
As you'll see once the seizure
hits, there's a lot of ugly
muscle activity.
All right.
Let's look at it.
Uh oh.
All right.
Let's look at it--
I thought I had put the links in
here that should have done
it, but who knows.
I know where to find them.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SINGING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So kind of scary.
Certainly when I've been seeing
them actually happen,
I've found it terrifying
to watch.
That kind of-- it's called
a tonic-clonic seizure.
They seem- I emphasize the word
'seem' -- unpredictable.
The interesting thing about
these seizures, or an
interesting thing, is they're
self-limiting.
In a few minutes, that young
lady or girl's seizure will be
over, not because anybody
intervened but because the
brain resets itself.
Then it will take--
in this case, probably took her
about an hour to recover
and get back to normal,
which is not good.
But after that, everything was
as before the seizure.
The difficulty is because
they're unpredictable, there
are huge injuries.
Imagine she'd been riding
a bicycle when that hit.
Well, something catastrophic.
Or more simply, imagine she'd
been going down a flight of
stairs or in a bathtub.
Any one of a number of things
would have resulted in this
potentially catastrophic
collateral damage after the
seizure or during the seizure.
And indeed people who
have epilepsy, you
can see their scars.
It's awful.
It can result in death, about
1 per 100 patient years.
It's called the sudden
unexpected
death in epilepsy patients.
So what we wanted to do is see
whether we could detect the
seizures and give a
little warning.
The notion being that even if
you couldn't do anything about
the seizure, if you could give
somebody, say, even five
seconds warning, they
could sit down
before they fell down.
They could get out of the tub.
They could back away
from the stove.
All sorts of things.
Furthermore, if you could use
technology to signal to
someone else that there was
about to be a seizure, help
could arrive.
Also potentially a good thing.
Turns out there are now some
fast-acting drugs that if you
put under the tongue can
ameliorate the seizure.
These have not yet been approved
by the FDA, but soon.
And we were particularly
interested in neural
stimulation.
If we ejected electrical current
into the brain at
exactly the right moment, could
we offset essentially
the effect of the seizure
and do a reset?
And maybe stop the seizure or
abort it, prevent it, or at
least reduce the long
term recovery time.
The thing to keep in mind for
the seizure is there were two
distinct onset times.
What you saw if you're looking
at the girl was what's called
the clinical onset, when there's
some clinical event.
If you were able to not look at
the person and instead look
at the EEG, not so easy, you
would have seen that there was
an electrographic onset that
preceded the clinical onset.
We know, in fact, since the
clinical effects are caused by
the electrical activity, there
will always be abnormal
electrical activity
prior to any
abnormal clinical activity.
And so the hope was that we
could detect the electrical
activity early.
Now that's not so easy.
What makes it hard is
that the EEG, the
electroencephalograph, differs
greatly across patients.
First of all, people with
epilepsy have abnormal
baseline EEG.
Even when they're not having a
seizure, bizarre things are
going on in their brains
electrically, all unusual things.
And so they don't
look like people
who don't have epilepsy.
And it varies tremendously
across patients.
So for about 35 years, people
attempted to build generic
detectors that would detect
seizures in everybody.
And they've not worked
well at all.
Every time a hospital buys an
EEG machine, it comes with a
detector built in.
And usually the first thing they
do is they turn them off
because the false alarm rate is
so high that it's like the
boy who cried wolf.
They're just saying seizure,
seizure, seizure, and people
start ignoring it.
The good news is it's pretty
consistent seizure onset for a
particular individual.
That suggests you should build
not generic detectors, but
patient specific detectors.
And we've been working
on using machine
learning to do that.
And in fact, it's been
highly successful.
We've done several retrospective
studies
indicating that it works
really well.
And we're now doing
a substantial
prospective study --
in progress at MGH.
And as part of that, we're
actually working at turning on
a neuro-stimulator that we hope
will attenuate the effect
of the seizure.
And I emphasize hope because we
don't have enough data to
know if it works.
It's part of what goes
on in this business.
But it's certainly been an
interesting project.
All right.
Heart attacks.
Let's look at that.
And I'll go to the easy
way to show them.
I should warn you, you're gonna
see something that's not
very pleasant.
You're actually gonna
see somebody die.
This was actually a person who
was playing in a soccer game
and died while the game
was being televised.
All right.
What I want to show you is this
didn't have to happen.
We're now gonna see another
televised soccer game where
the player had exactly the same
event but with a rather
different outcome.
So look at the upper center of
field and you'll see the
person has collapsed, much the
same way it happened before.
Now watch the body convulse.
You'll see the knees
kick up there.
And now comes the miracle.
He sits up.
He leaves the field and, in
fact, he later asked if he can
reenter the game.
The coach, to the coach's
everlasting credit, said no.
Clearly the right decision.
So it's amazing really
that this happens.
So what was the difference
between the two?
well, we see this here.
There are things you can do.
So in acute coronary syndrome,
think of it as some sort of a
heart attack.
They're very common, about
one and a quarter million
per year in the US.
15% to 20% of these people will
suffer a cardiac-related
death within the next
four years.
If you could figure out who
were the people at highest
risk of different events and
choose the treatment properly,
for example, implant an
implantable cardiac
defibrillator, you could
save these lives.
And that was what we
saw in our movies.
That the first patient, first
person, the one who died, did
not have a defibrillator.
The second person, the one
who survived, did.
So he collapsed on the field.
The defibrillator sensed that
his heart had stopped, gave it
an electric shock.
You've all seen this in
television where they put the
paddles on and they
say, clear.
And then there's this moment of
drama where everyone stares
at the EKG machine, and it
goes from a flat line to
suddenly up and down, and
everyone goes, ah.
Well that's exactly what
happened here.
And that convulsion was this
huge electrical shock getting
sent through the person's body
which restarted the heart,
saved his life.
Probably, if the other player
had had an ICD, he would not
have died either.
So great technology.
Well, yes and no.
This was a study in the New
England Journal of Medicine
not so long ago, a very good
control study, where they
matched patients with ICDs and
patients without ICDs and over
72 months tracked which ones
lived and which ones died.
Well, the disturbing news is
there isn't much difference
between the red line
and the blue line.
So these people had what was
essentially a, well, which was
about a $50,000 implant and
various kinds of risks and
inconvenience and discomfort,
et cetera, and on average it
didn't save lives.
Oh, dear.
In fact, 90% of the people who
got them-- and this is not
just in this study.
This is in every study- receives
zero, actually less
than zero medical benefit
from the ICD.
How do we know that?
Well, remember, it only turns on
when it senses the heart is
in trouble.
For 90% of the people who get
it, it never energizes because
the heart doesn't
get in trouble,
or detectable trouble.
So what we see, if we look at
a little more detail in this
study, is that for sudden
cardiac death, the kind of
death we saw in those videos,
or non-death,
the ICD reduces that.
Unfortunately, it increases
other causes of death, for
example, infections related to
the surgery, et cetera, those
unfortunate hospital acquired
infections, for example, we
talked about earlier.
So what we see here is we have
a technology that if we knew
whose heart was likely to
stop or go into serious
fibrillation, beating
uncontrollably, and we only
gave those people ICDs,
we could save an
enormous number of lives.
But currently we don't know
who's in that population, and
therefore we don't know
who should get them.
So we use other mechanisms
deciding who should get them.
And we're wrong most of the
time, doing more harm than
good on those patients
for whom we're wrong.
OK.
Well, how do the people
predict it today?
The usual things.
Are you male or female?
Do you have high
blood pressure?
Diabetes?
What's your cholesterol level?
BMP?
Various other kinds of things.
Electrocardiograms,
which look at--
it's an echo cardiogram
that looks at the
activity of the heart.
Is the blood flowing
through it OK?
EKGs.
Many different methods for
analyzing the electrical
activity, et cetera.
We played with many of
these techniques.
The one I want to tell you about
today, because it's the
most closely related to 6.00
material, is what we think of
the Tolstoy approach to
risk stratification.
So Tolstoy is famous for saying
that happy families are
all alike, but every
unhappy family is
unhappy in its own way.
So we generalize that, or
specialized it maybe, to say
that happy hearts are all alike,
but every unhappy heart
is different, and then did some
fairly simple work to
quantify the difference between
electrical activities
in different people's hearts,
converting it to symbols.
You don't have to worry
about that.
We used dynamic programming as
an important part because we
were looking at roughly a
billion heart beats and so we
needed to make it run fast.
And then we used clustering to
identify patients whose hearts
we thought were similar
to one another.
Here are some results.
These are people who had an
acute coronary syndrome.
So the dominant group, the
biggest group, the quote
"people who we thought were
most likely to be fine"--
because remember, most
people are fine
after a heart attack--
457 patients in this particular
data set.
And you can see that they
did pretty well.
A very small fraction
of them died.
Can't see it from this angle,
but come out here.
Yeah, less than 1%.
But then we looked at
people who were
in these other clusters.
And in fact, we used a glomerate
of hierarchical
clustering to do this.
And in cluster A, which had 53
patients, well, 3.77% died.
If you happened to fall
in cluster C, you were
at very high risk.
And we can just see that there's
a big difference here.
And so the notion is could we
have used this to predict in
advance who was most likely to
benefit from the various kinds
of treatments?
All right.
Again, very quick just to
give you the details--
not the details, the overview
that the kinds of things that
we cover in this course are
actually quite useful in
solving real practical
problems.
All right.
Let me wrap up the term.
So I hope most of you feel
you've come a long way--
maybe you prefer this picture.
That if you think about the
kinds of problems and
struggles you had three months
ago in getting tiny little
programs to work and think about
how easy those would be
for you today, you should have
some appreciation that you've
really taught yourself a lot.
And you really taught it to
yourself, by doing the problem
sets, in many ways, right.
We've tried to help, but
learning is very much up to
the individual who's
doing the learning.
But I'm certainly impressed in
looking at the kinds of really
pretty complicated problems
you guys can now solve.
We looked at six major topics.
Clearly, you learned a notation
for expressing
computations, and
that was Python.
And I hope you don't think
that's the only notation you
can use and that if you take
a course that uses MATLAB,
you'll say, oh, this
is just the same.
It's easy.
Or Java or anything else.
Learning programming
languages is easy.
Once you've learned one, the
next one is much easier.
Harder was learning about the
process of writing and
debugging programs.
You've learned that, I think,
largely through experience.
You've learned about the process
of moving from a
problem statement, something
as vague as should shuttle
buses be bigger or faster
to improve service, to a
computational formulation of the
problem and a method for
solving a problem.
And we've looked at lots
of different methods.
You've learned basic recipes,
algorithms, things like
dynamic programming, things
like depth-first search,
things like decision trees,
that you'll be able to use
again and again.
The good news is there are only
a really small number of
important recipes.
And once you've mastered those,
you just use them over
and over again to solve
new problems.
Spent a lot of time on using
simulations to shed light on
problems that don't
easily succumb
to closed form solutions.
And I think that's really
the place where
computation is so important.
There are a lot of problems
where you can turn them into a
set of differential equations,
maybe solve the equations, and
you're done.
Oh, we'll write programs to do
those because we're lazy.
But in principle,
you could solve
those without a computer.
But in fact, the thing you can't
do without a computer is
these messy problems that are
most of what goes on in the
real world, where there's
randomness, and things like
that, and there is no
simple formula that
gives you the answer.
And what you have to do is write
a simulation and run it
and see what goes on.
And that's why we spent so
much time on simulation
because it really is
increasingly the
thing people use.
And we learned about how to
use computational tools to
help model and understand data,
how to do [?] plots, a
small amount of statistics,
machine learning, just
dealing with data.
Why Python?
It's pretty easy to
learn to use.
Compared to most other
programming languages like,
say, C++ or Java,
Python is easy.
The syntax is simple.
It's interpretive, which
makes debugging easier.
You don't have to worry about
managing memory as you do in,
say, C, right.
You get a big list or
dictionary, and
magically it exists.
And when you don't need it
any more, it's gone.
It's modern.
It supports the currently
stylish mode of
object-oriented programming in
a nice way with its classes
and things like that.
So indeed what you would hear
about in a Java class, we can
cover almost all the
interesting things with Python.
And it's increasingly popular.
It's used in an increasing
number of subjects at MIT.
A lot of course 6 subjects, but
also a lot of course 20
subjects, course 9 subjects,
over and over again.
It's becoming, probably, the
most popular language at MIT
and at other universities.
Increasingly it's used
in industry.
And as you've seen with PyLab,
the libraries are amazing.
And so PyLab, Random, et cetera,
there's just a lot of
stuff you can get for free
if you're living in
the world of Python.
The main thing in writing,
testing, and bugging programs,
I hope you've learned, is to
take it a step at a time.
Understand the problem.
Think about the overall
structure and algorithms
separately of how you express
them in the programming
language, right.
We can talk about dynamic
programming conceptually
without worrying about
how to code it up.
Always break the problem
into small parts.
Identify useful abstractions.
Code and test each unit
independently.
Worry about functionality
first.
Get it to work.
Get it to give you
the right answer.
Then worry about making it
do that more quickly.
But separate those things.
Start with some pseudo code.
Then above all, be systematic.
When debugging, think about
the scientific method of
forming hypotheses, forming
experiments that can test the
hypotheses, running
the experiment,
checking the results.
Don't try and do
it too quickly.
Just be slow and careful.
Slow and steady will win
the race in debugging.
And when your program
behaves badly--
and the sad news is no matter
how many years you spend at
it, you will write programs that
don't work the way you
think they should
the first time--
ask yourself why it did what it
did, not why didn't it do
what you wanted to do.
It's a lot easier to debug
from the how come it's
behaving the way it is then why
isn't it behaving the way
I want it to behave.
In going from problem statement
to computation,
break the problem into
smaller problems.
Try and relate your problem to
a problem that somebody else,
ideally, has already solved.
For example, is it a
knapsack problem?
Is it a shortest path problem?
If so, good, I know how
to solve those.
Think about what kind of output
you might want to see.
What should the plots be like?
I usually design the output
before I design the program.
Often you can formulate things
as an optimization problem.
Pull back.
Say, well, can I formulate this
as finding the minimum or
maximum values satisfying an
objective function and some
set of constraints?
If I can, it's an optimization
problem, and therefore I know
how to attack it.
And don't be afraid to think
about approximate solutions.
Sometimes you're just gonna not
actually be able to solve
the problem you want to solve.
And so you'll find a solution to
a simpler problem, and that
will be good enough.
Sometimes you can actually solve
the problem by finding a
series of solutions that
approaches, but may never
reach, a perfect answer.
Probably the third week in the
course, we looked at Newton's
method as an example of
that kind of problem.
And then there are algorithms.
We looked at big O notation,
various kinds of algorithms, a
lot of kinds.
You've already - I sent a list
of specific algorithms.
And particularly, we looked
at optimization problems.
We spent a lot of time on
modeling the world, keeping in
mind that the models
are always wrong.
But nevertheless, they're
often useful.
They provide abstractions
of reality.
So we looked at two kinds of
simulation models, Monte Carlo
and queuing networks.
We looked at statistical models,
for example, linear
regression.
And we looked at some graph
theoretic models.
Those are not the only
techniques, but they're very
useful techniques.
We looked at making
sense of data.
We talked about statistical
techniques.
How to use them well.
How to use them badly.
We looked at plotting.
And we spent some time on
machine learning, supervised
and unsupervised and feature
vectors, and spent a lot of
time talking about how do you
choose the features, because
fundamentally that's typically
the difference between success
and failure in the world
of machine learning.
Throughout it all, the pervasive
themes were the
power of abstraction and
systematic problem solving.
So what's next?
Many of you have worked really
hard this semester.
We know that.
And the TAs and LAs and
I all appreciate that.
And I thank you sincerely
for the effort you
put into the course.
Only you know your return
on the investment.
I hope it's good.
Remember as you go forward in
your careers that you can now
write programs to solve problems
you need to solve.
Don't be afraid to do it.
If you like this, there are
plenty of other CS courses
that you now could take.
You're actually equipped,
probably, to take any one of
these four courses based upon
what you've learned in 6.00.
You could major in course 6 or
think about the new major in
computer science and
molecular biology.
And you're certainly qualified
to go off and to look for
UROPs that involve serious
programming.
All right.
Wrapping up with some famous
last words, these were words
that some famous people said
as they were about to die.
An actor, Douglas Fairbanks
senior, was asked by a family
member, how are you feeling?
He said, never felt better.
And then that was the last
thing he ever said.
In contrast, the last thing
Luther Burbank was reported to
have said, a famous scientist,
was, I don't feel so good.
He was a scientist rather
than actor.
He had a better appreciation
of the state of the world.
Conrad Hilton, who you probably
think of as Paris
Hilton's grandfather, but
actually is more well known in
some circles for running the
Hilton hotels, his last words
when his family asked him-- they
knew he was dying-- is
there anything you
want us to know
about running the business?
And he said, yes, leave the
shower curtain on the inside
of the tub.
And that's advice, I have to
confess, my wife has given me
on several occasions.
Archimedes, basically before
he was taken away and
executed, asked, could he please
finish solving the
problem he was working on.
You know, I could imagine some
poor 6.00 student who's about
to be carted away by the police
saying, can I finish my
problem set first, please?
Actually, I can't
imagine that.
And finally, this US Civil War
general, John Sedgwick, was
reputedly--
and this is, I believe, a true
story-- said, talking about
the snipers from the other side
who were quite far away,
that telling his people, don't
be afraid, they couldn't get
an elephant at this distance.
And if you go to the site of the
battle, you'll find this
plaque describing the death of
John Sedgwick who was shot and
killed immediately upon saying
this by one of said snipers.
It says something about generals
that probably is
still true today.
All right, quick reminders
and then we're done.
There's a final exam.
If you haven't done the
underground guide, go do it.
These are things I said at the
beginning of the lecture.
I'm just repeating them.
Thanks a lot.
Good luck in the final 6.00,
all your finals.
And then more importantly,
have a great summer.